- Welcome back to Bucket-O-Pups,
the only game show where
you get to fill a bucket
full of puppies.
We have three contestants here today.
Sara, say hello to the audience.
- Howdy.
- Briana.
- Hello.
- And Curly.
- Hey, guys.
- You have 30 seconds
to put as many puppies
in this bucket as possible.
If the puppies escape, feel
free to put them back in.
Only one puppy at a time.
No double fisting with puppies.
Curly's first.
30 seconds.
Let it go.
(whimsical music)
Oh, we have an escapee.
Five,
- [All] four, three, two, one.
(clanging)
- Three puppies in the bucket.
How'd you feel about Curly's performance?
- I thought he did well.
- Yeah, you think you can beat three?
- That bitch has nothing on me.
- Is everybody getting ready?
And unleash the hounds.
(dramatic music)
That's one in the bucket.
One in the bucket.
Oh, look at this, two in the bucket.
Three, Briana, here we go.
Oh, four in the bucket.
Down to three.
And four.
Five, four,
three, two, one.
(clanging)
Four puppies for Briana in the bucket.
Four puppies, how do you feel about that?
- I can do five.
- Five puppies, all right.
Get the timer set, go.
One puppy in the bucket.
Two puppies.
Three puppies in the bucket.
Four puppies in the bucket.
Five, four, three.
Five, oh, down to three.
Four.
Three, two, one.
(clanging)
Five puppies in the bucket.
And today's winner in Bucket-O-Pups,
Sara, congratulations,
five puppies in the bucket.
(exciting music)
[All] Bucket-O-Pups!